pausa en este vídeo y traten de
encontrar el área de este triángulo les
voy a dar dos pistas pueden identificar
que este es un triángulo isósceles y
otra pista es que el teorema de
pitágoras puede ser muy útil muy bien
resolvamos esto juntos entonces debemos
recordar que el área de un triángulo es
igual a un medio por la base por la
altura aquí nos dan la base la base es
10 pero cuál es la altura nuestra altura
es igual a la longitud de esta línea que
tenemos aquí
si podemos obtener la altura entonces
podremos calcular cuánto es un medio por
la base por la altura pero como
obtenemos esta altura bueno aquí es
donde nos sirve saber que este es un
triángulo isósceles un triángulo
isósceles tiene dos lados del mismo
tamaño y por lo tanto estos dos ángulos
de la base son congruentes y tenemos
esta línea que es la altura del
triángulo entonces sabemos que estos
ángulos son ángulos rectos así que si
tenemos dos triángulos los cuales tienen
dos ángulos iguales
sabemos que el tercer ángulo va a ser
igual así que este ángulo va a ser
congruente con este entonces si tenemos
dos triángulos y esto puede ser obvio
que tienen dos ángulos en común y el
lado de en medio de ellos es común es la
misma longitud esto significa que son
triángulos congruentes ahora reconocemos
que estos triángulos son congruentes los
dos tienen un lado que mide trece los
dos tienen un lado común este lado azul
y los dos tienen un lado cuya longitud
es la mitad de 10
este 5 y la longitud de este lado es 5
cómo es que pude deducir esto podrían
decir que esto es intuitivamente
correcto pero soy un poco más rigurosa
aquí cuando digo que estos son dos
triángulos congruentes podemos dividir
este 10 entre 2 porque este lado es
igual a este y suman 10 muy bien ahora
podemos usar el teorema de pitágoras
para obtener la longitud de este lado
azul o la altura del triángulo si a este
lado le llamamos h el teorema de
pitágoras nos dice que h cuadrada más 5
al cuadrado es igual a 13 al cuadrado h
cuadrada más 5 al cuadrado
es igual a 13 al cuadrado es igual que
nuestro lado más largo o nuestra
hipotenusa al cuadrado entonces 5 al
cuadrado es 25 13 al cuadrado es 169
podemos restar 25 de los dos lados para
despejar a h cuadrada y cuál es el
resultado nos queda h cuadrada es igual
esto lo cancelamos y 169 menos 25 es 144
ahora si estamos haciendo esto de una
manera puramente matemática podríamos
decir que ha hecho podría ser más 12 o
menos 12 pero estamos calculando una
distancia así que nos enfocaremos en el
valor positivo entonces h es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de 144 y h es igual a 12
resolvimos esto pero recuerden que no
nos están pidiendo solo la altura de
este triángulo tenemos que calcular el
área el área es un medio de la base por
la altura bueno sabemos de antemano que
nuestra base es este 10 que tenemos aquí
vamos a ponerlo de otro color
así que nuestra base es esta distancia
que mide 10 y ahora conocemos la altura
la altura es 12 ahora solo tenemos que
resolver esto un medio por 10 por 12
bueno esto va a ser igual a un medio por
10 5 por 12 es igual a 60 60 unidades
cuadradas cualesquiera que sean nuestras
unidades esta es nuestra área